hello everyone and welcome to another
interesting game from round nine of the
uh v8hs.com grand swiss it's david
howell versus anton korobov and we
mentioned yesterday that uh howell is on
a nice winning streak and then we're
gonna cover one of his games um as he's
now tied for first place with uh caruana
and dalireza uh and this is one uh one
of
those games um uh for for from around
nine also a quarterback up until this
point did not lose a single game so he's
having a pretty great tournament and
howell did lose one game but he lost the
game to fabi and then he got three wins
in a row so that's pretty pretty awesome
but this game it's a really short one
and it really uh shows you the power of
the light square bishop when playing the
queen's indian defense so uh let's check
it out so how with the white pieces
opens with knight to f3 uh so we start
off with the already opening we have
knight to f6 c4 we have e6 g3 and now b6
preparing for this uh early uh queen
side fianchetto uh we have bishop to g2
bishop to b7 and now d4 grabbing more
space uh here in the center so this is
now uh transposition into the queen's
indian defense we have bishop to e7 and
after both players castle we are in the
classical variation of the of the
queen's indian defense uh we have rook
to e1 now hoping for some knight to c3
and e4 but of course black always puts a
knight to e4 as the bishop already
controls this square so we have knight
to a6 um now we want to play c5 at some
point we have knight to c3 and of course
knight to e4 not allowing white to play
e4 uh we have bishop to d2 and now there
are a couple of moves you could play
here d5 is very popular uh pavolanov
played d6 here against levon uh and uh
he he lost that game but here we have f5
and it's uh also just uh aimed towards
uh just the control of that e4 square so
here we have knight to e5 saying that
okay you can never move this knight
because the bishop on b7 will hang
and although you could maybe go go for a
discovery here because now a white queen
is under attack but you don't really
gain all that much yes you can capture
capture but now uh you can't really play
d6 because knight to c6 picks up the
bishop here so we're going to have play
some like bishop f6 and then b4 and the
white is um
well just fine here so instead after
knight to e5 we have d6 by korobov and
it is now uh only as of move 10 that we
have a completely new game so let's see
how uh david continues this we've knight
back to d3 uh and now comes bishop to f6
so attacking that undefended d4 pawn and
while you could defend it with e3 uh
david plays knight captures on e4 and
this is now the the good stuff f
captures on e4 and now e3 saying that
okay you're welcome to capture here but
then i capture on b7 and it's game over
white wins here so of course black
cannot play this so here uh you could
try something like queen to e8 as um
well this pawn is very weak you could
play knight to f4 go after it bishop to
h3 go after it even queen to g4 could go
after that pawn so it makes sense to add
some defense to this pawn and also maybe
prepare some like queen to g6 if y
doesn't bring the queen to g4 uh but
here e5 was played right away and now uh
this only helps white really so here we
have queen to g4
uh and here we have queen to c8 offering
a queen trait and david goes for this we
have queen captures in c8 rook a
captures on c8 and now d captures an e5
so everything with tempo d captures on
e5 and bishop to c3 now uh with a double
attack on the e5 pawn and this knight is
still annoying on d3 can't be captured
because bishop captures again wins on
the spot uh so here we have rook f the
e8 defending the uh the e5 pawn and now
uh even b4 so still uh not worrying
about this knight and now only now we
have rook c to d8 uh and now rook a to
d1 so again the knight cannot really be
captured uh and here uh we have finally
bishop the a8 so now the bishop is no
longer undefended now this is a threat
and the white needs to move move the
knight so knight to c1 and black finally
gets this c5 moving and this is pretty
much um
all that you could have hoped for you
have this very nice structure on the
queen side you have the knight here
ready to come to c7 to e6 you have the
light square bishop not a fully
operational but uh you know
semi-operational this e4 pawn really is
a problem because it uh only blocks your
own bishop and it also uh serves as a
target to the white bishop if your own
bishop ever moves or gets traded off so
here we have b5
attacking the knight knight to c7 and
now uh h4
uh basically asking black what do you
play here black goes knight to e6 this
was his plan all along and now we have
rook capture 78 rook captures and now
knight to b3 and this is a beautiful
move knight to b3 because the knight on
c1 seems like it's doing good work it's
preventing rook to d3 but if you want to
go after the e5 pawn you have to play
knight to b3 followed by knight to d2
not e5 d4 pawn and then we go after the
e for pawn uh and there's uh well
nothing black can do to prevented this
so black after knight to b3 plays a rook
to d3 but
the rook doesn't have all that much to
do there we have rook to c1 defending
our bishop and now after g5 we have
knight to d2 and now we are ready to
capture this pawn uh but this is how
black decided to to
treat this disposition so interestingly
g captures on h4 although very ugly it's
probably the best black has here for
example if knight capture is going after
the bishop we might see captures
captures and now the rook has to move
rook back to d8 now we capture an h4 and
you can't really capture here because
the e5 pawn is hanging so black would be
down upon white's position would be
better he would have the bishop pair and
with perfect play this uh well should be
winning for white so uh this is if you
go for what's objectively best so
korobov goes for knights the d4 he
offers uh
a piece here although uh it
it's probably not a real offer so feel
free to pause the video here and try to
find a move that completely uh destroys
black here well i give you a couple of
seconds
[Music]
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting why
alpha zero said that the queen's indian
defense is just a you know useless
opening and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it is bishop back
to f1 we attacked the rook the rook has
nowhere to go and we're going to win it
of course not for free we're going to
give up two pieces but it all works out
for the best because it's as if black is
down a piece and if you guys were
wondering what happens if you actually
capture the knight well then you give
black a bit too much you don't want to
play against this you can't move the
bishop because the knight hangs so you
you're going to have to give up
something you're going to have to play
bishop captures on e4 the captures
you're going to play bishop captures and
d3c captures rook to d1 and now for
example
bishop to c3 we defend our pawn here and
yes you can capture on g5 but it's still
very ugly black has this wonderful
bishop pair now the light square bishop
comes alive and it's not that easy to
play this with white even though you're
up the exchange so uh david goes for the
absolute best move that is bishop to f1
and now we have rook capture sunday to
bishop capture on d2 and of course
knight to f3 check we're going to pick
up the bishop here so king g2 knight
captures on d2 but here comes the
problem of the entire idea rook to d1
now the rook is coming up the board and
these bishops really have no
no good squares uh so here you might
consider knight to f3 just trying to
keep the knight in the game but it
doesn't do all that much for example
captures captures rook to d7 we capture
the a7 pawn and it's a much much better
position for white uh so horrible tried
to trade off the knight knight captures
on f1 and here we have rook to d7 and
now uh what do you play here it's a
really ugly position for black there
really isn't a good move uh and corvo
just uh tries to give the knight back
but on a d2 square so the rook has to go
back there was a very interesting um uh
approach here that that could be
possible with bishop to b7 it doesn't
work but it's so interesting that i have
to show it to you now the point is uh
what do you play here if you capture the
bishop with rook captures on b7 we
simply play knight to d2 and now black
has compensation for this if h captures
the bishop captures we're going to
capture on a7 now knight captures on c4
and this isn't all that bad for black so
what you would have to do after bishop
to b7 you would have to capture on f1
with the king and now we attack the rook
and once the rook captures on a7 now we
play bishop to e6 and go after this c
for pawn uh and it looks like um
you don't uh have all that much rook to
a4 is much much too slow so this doesn't
really work but after a4 it's still
gonna be uh uh winning for white but
it's it's very very interesting for
example bishop captures on c4 with check
king to g2 now even bishop to d5 ready
to start pushing your past pawn but now
let's say captures captures and rook d7
we challenge the bishop bishop to a6 now
rook b7 and now we are ready to push so
black of course will also push rook
captures on v6 king to f7 defends the
bishop let's say a5 and now we have to
play c3 we're going to play a6 bishop d5
to prevent rook to c6 but adjust rook to
b8 and there's really nothing uh
black can do about this once you push c2
rook c8 and that's it you're never
queening that pawn uh but it's a very
very interesting and it's a very
annoying defense so you know maybe maybe
a good try but uh you know
it probably wouldn't work uh but instead
knight the d2 was played now we have
rook captures on d2 bishop to b7 and
just rook back to d6 and he was in this
position on move 33 that anton corbel
resigned to the game as there is nothing
more to be done here your bishop is
hanging and regardless of what you do
that bishop will uh fall or or this
which bishop will fall for example if
you move the bishop back we can just
play rook to d7 and this bishop has no
squares uh you have no squares you have
a8 or c8 but regardless you're gonna
deliver check and pick up the bishop and
if you don't move this bishop if you
defend it with the king with some like
king to f7 then of course rook d7 check
picks up the bishop straight away
uh so yeah that's uh
uh that's the way it happened on move 33
cordoba resigned and another example of
why alpha zero really dislikes the
queen's indian defense because there's a
really no way to
you use your light square bishop if
white really knows what he's doing and
this is obviously
just another example of that of course
maybe after another stronger version of
uh such an ai comes along and says no
it's actually the greatest opening then
everyone will play it but for the moment
uh it has a really really bad reputation
uh so yeah once again that's the game
hope you guys enjoyed it now uh like we
said we have three people in the lead
fabiano corona david howell here and uh
and it will be uh first versus howell uh
in round 10 and karwana versus mvl so
we're going to see what happens in round
10 can first bounce back or will howell
maybe get his uh
fifth win in a row uh you know it's
going to be it's going to be a crazy day
so once again i hope you guys enjoyed it
i would like to thank tom derala forest
muhammad alif assassin faiz and
alessandro atura for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check all
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing uh the coverage of this
spectacular event checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world thank you i
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your weekend